dans moins de 24 heures
elles auront enfilé leurs casques et
leurs combinaisons ces filles là sont
accro au sport automobile pilote ou co
pilote d'une discipline où les hommes
rien tant m et pourtant aussi donc je me
souviens ya toujours eu des périodes où
il ya eu des femmes même avant que je
sois là il y avait à l'époque martine
grangenois hélène saint pry c'était dans
les années 80
10 je crois à peu près en des temps en
temps on taquine quand on dit toujours
aubry fine bouche et messieurs les
pilotes indienne où les filles mais oui
mais bon c'est juste pour jouer le jeu
marais on est avant tout des pilotes
katia est la plus expérimentée bientôt
vingt ans de pilotage
caroline elle est la dernière arrivée du
groupe
elle reprend le sport auto en tant que
copilote après deux jeunes années de
sport de haut niveau sur les circuits du
karting
alors quand elle accompagne ses
collègues sur les lieux d'une future
course elle prête attention aux moindres
détails
revêtement s'il ya de la boue s'il ya
des endroits où ça va prendre la corde
et que ça va mettre de la boue la météo
un petit peu s'ils se trompent pas trop
et puis après le niveau d'adhérence
là c'est très gras donc earth et s'armer
de la pluie ça va glisser beaucoup
demain un emmanuel c'est la benjamine du
groupe
tout juste 22 ans mais déjà trois
saisons en tant que copilote
en attendant un jour d'avoir le budget
pour s'offrir sa propre voiture
ça m'a toujours expliquer ces milieux là
le milieu du monde du sport automobile
et je me suis dit pourquoi pas j'habite
fait pas le moine je voyais souvent les
courses avec la meilleure l'adrénaline
c'est une incitation forte qui viennent
c'est le besoin d'eux
un peu le goût du risque c'est pas si le
colis à ça mais c'est un peu ça
passionné depuis l'enfance maeva vient
de s'acheter sa première voiture de
course au volant de sa twingo elle
découvre de nouvelles sensations son
premier rallye il ya quelques semaines
sa deuxième course de côtes au galion
là la difficulté des galions en tout cas
vous
ouais le temps
denis raguet
bien beaucoup de vent
sage de rapport
et il
[Musique]
une boîte automatique
enfin pour sandrine c'est une histoire
de famille
la mécanique elle est tombée dedans
depuis tout petit un père pilote qui
l'amène pour de l'assistance publique
près de sa voiture en double monte
jusqu'à s'imposer dans un milieu
d'hommes
on a notre place dans ces messieurs le
savent ces dames le savent donc et on
essaie de leur faire peur de temps en
temps et de les mettre derrière des
pilotes et des copilotes au féminin la
gente féminine a bien l'intention de
faire parler d'elle pour les prochaines
saisons auto